попри військову агресію Російської
Федерації навчальний процес в Україні
триває минулорічна освітньому фронті
було багато перемог і здобутків очно
дистанційно змішано в залежності від
безпекової ситуації в кожному регіоні
але освітній процес не припиняється
багато закладів фахової передвищої та
вищої освіти перейшли на дистанційне
навчання Утім абітурієнти які цьогоріч
отримають атестат про середню освіту ще
не мають алгоритму вступу у виші проте
якою буде вступна кампанія уже у новому
23-му році поговоримо із міністром
освіти і науки України сергіям шкарлутом
пане Сергію наші вітання
Доброго дня Дякую за увагу до освіти до
питання освіти адже це про майбутнє
Слава Україні Героям слава Отже п Сергію
Наприкінці листопада Кабмін вніс до
парламенту законопроект щодо вступної
кампанії у 2023 році але депутати Його
поки не затвердили водночас а-а
зареєстрували два власних проєкти і в
Раді вже говорять що остаточне рішення
можуть ухвалити аж у березні ми
розуміємо що початок вступної кампанії
переважно він починається в липні тож
часу має вистачити Чи це може бути
запізно Дуже дякую вам за запитання ви
знаєте те що
перебіг і саме подачі документів
відбувається в липні не означає те що ми
можемо в навіть під липень приймати такі
важливі закони і
законопроект дійсно в листопаді місяці
Міністерство внесло Урядовий
законопроект щодо підготовки до вступної
кампанії проведення саме
моделі вступу хочу сказати що на
сьогодні єдиним інструментом вступу до
закладів вищої фахове передвищої освіти
залишається зовнішнє незалежне
оцінювання і
аналог його національним
мультипрем'єрний тест який
застосовувався в 22-му році мав лише
тимчасовий характер і застосовувався
виключно тільки для 22-го року яким
чином буде це проходити Ми сподіваємось
що окрім двох ще альтернативних
законопроектів сьогодні на підкомітеті
під керівництвом Юлії Миколаївна
грішової було конструктивно розглянуто
всі варіанти всі можливості які
запропонували і Міністерство і автори
інших законопроектів і сподіваюсь що ми
найближчим чином знайдемо тот консенсус
щодо проведення
вступної кампанії на 2023 рік робота
триває не на день не зупиняється адже ми
чітко розуміємо що молодь як має як
найраніше знати особливості вступу до
закладів вищої фахової перевищення
освіти в цьому році Ви знаєте не те що
Те щось сам вступ починається сам прийом
документів в липні місяці адже
реєстрація починається завжди січень
лютий і тому нам важливо
як прийняти
саму саму модель прийому на 23 рік і
саме на цими зараз і працюємо пана
Сергія Ну у будь-якому разі вступна
кампанія відбудеться у форматі
національного мультиппредметного тесту
який вже проходила абітурієнти минулого
року але у Верховній Раді наразі лунають
різні пропозиції щодо його формату От
наприклад
розділити складання цього національного
мультимедійного тесту на два дні або
дати можливість випускникам обирати між
складанням іноземної мови до прикладу та
історії України як ви ставитеся до таких
пропозицій саме це
наші фахівці фахівці Міністерства освіти
і науки озвучували на комітет на
підкомітеті
з позиції Міністерства завжди була
надконструктивна з
урахуванням позиції і самих абітурієнтів
і батьків і це мабуть найголовніше
сьогодні підстава для формування наших
пропозицій я особисто відвідую область
України зустрічає з батьками з вчителями
з майбутнім абітурієнтами на сьогодні
Питання в тому Міністерство категорично
буде стояти на позиції в тому щоб
проведення відбувалось виключно в один
день адже якщо ми будемо розтягувати 2 3
4 тоді чим це буде відрізнятися від
класичного ЗНО і яким чином воно Скажімо
так враховує небезпеку воєнного стану
який є сьогодні в державі один день але
при цьому Ми чітко усвідомлюємо що ту
базу яка формує найбільшу
прогностичну валідність знань
абітурієнтів або школярів це є історія
України математика і і українська мова і
при цьому Ми будемо враховувати
варіативні з
в дітей до різних вступів наприклад на
інженерні спеціальності або нам
спеціальності медичного профілю або на
гуманітарні ми будемо четвертим
предметом пропонувати це все буде в
комп'ютерному варіанті так як вже
відбувалось 22-му році пропонувати до
цих трьох базових предметів або це буде
іноземна мова або хімія або Фізика або
біологія і в цьому контексті абітурієнт
зможе сам обирати для себе ту той
комплект в дисциплін який він може як
найкраще здати і забути зарахованим до
національних закладів вищої фахової
передвищої освіти саме це є основа
формування вступної кампанії 22-го року
і 23-го року зберегти якомога більше
дітей які вступили до закладів вищої
фахової перевищення освіти і профтехо в
Україні це самі основний меседж який
сьогодні переслідує Міністерство п
Сергію а зауваження громадськості були
враховані тому що ми знаємо що ви
запрошували долучатися до обговорення
основних положень проекту зокрема
порядку прийому і навчання для здобуття
вищої освіти у 23-му році
що висловлювали
що було прийнято що ні
ви знаєте 54 листи 237 пропозиції які
надійшли під час громадського
обговорення саме порядку прийому на
навчання
більшість із них в принципі повторювали
один-одне але саме головне - це один
день тестування на цьому
наполягають саме батьки і забезпечити
варіативність вступу до різних типів
освітніх програм тому в цьому контексті
більшість ми до них більшість пропозицій
ми врахували але при цьому наразі ми ще
здійснюємо певне угрупування потреб і це
вже при формуванні саме моделей вступу і
виписані умов прийоми теж будемо
більшість пропозицій в рахунку пане
Сергію знаємо і розуміємо що левова
частка державних коштів наразі
спрямована на безпеку та оборона нашої
держави однак нещодавно у мінфіні
повідомили що в бюджеті на оцей рік 23-й
попри економічну ситуацію передбачали
майже 5,5 мільярдів гривень на розвиток
інклюзивної освіти як планують витратити
ці кошти І на що можуть розраховувати
особи з особливими освітніми потребами
та їхні родичі ви знаєте держава має
ставитись до своїх громадян незалежно
від того в якому вони стані які вони
мають потреби ставитися однаково і
піклуватися про свої громадян саме це
стосується такої особливої категорії
дітей з особливими освітніми потребами і
саме з цих 5-5 мільярдів Ми плануємо три
групи видатків які будуть
використовуватись в цілому 23-му році це
3,9 млрд це педагогічний супровід більше
ніж 32 тисяч дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами це і йдеться мова По
оплату праці про нарахування асистента
вчителя фахівцям які забезпечують
організацію інклюзивної освіти в
закладах освіти 1,2 млрд грн це оцінка
розвитку дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами і 0,03 млрд грн - це на
підтримку понад 45 тисяч дітей
особливими освітніми потребами всі ці
додатки чітко прописані в
порядку використання і я сподіваюсь що
від того наскільки держава піклується
про дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами свідчить про розвиток і про
зрілість держави щодо входження і в
європейських процес і в світові світовій
моделі розвитку освіти тут важливо так
зі світом рухатися в ногу а українські
школярі зараз починають повертатися із
зимових канікул до навчання і в Одесі
зокрема повідомили що понад 10 000
школярів у другому семестрі вирішили
навчатися очно хоча наприкінці першого
семестру в грудні таких було вдвічі
менше а Чи можете ви повідомити які
тенденції в інших регіонах Чи можна
говорити про те що більше школярів їхніх
батьків вибирають очну форму навчання
дуже Дякую це дуже слушно і дуже гарне
запитання адже адже воно свідчить про от
сам відсоток того скільки батьки і діти
сприймають навчання в учному або в
змішаному форматі з елементами очного
навчання свідчить про довіру батьків
самих учасників освітнього процесу до
дій і намірів держави щодо забезпечення
формування взагалі картини освітнього
процесу по всій території держави Хочу
зазначити що майже
71% майже 71% шкіл працювали в форматі
або очного або в змішаного навчання з
елементами очного тобто
приблизно і ще десь приблизно 30% це
було жорстке навчання в онлайні оскільки
це території які межують з
кордоном бойових дій це території
потенційно небезпечні або окремі заклади
які ще не мають укриття і можливості
можливості Навчатися або формувати
безпековий протокол під час повітряних
тривог дійсно ви на прикладі Одеси
взагалі вражаюча картина коли
втричі на сьогодні на початок нового
семестру збільшена кількість дітей які
готові Приступити до очного навчання це
свідчить про Ну скажімо
дії місцевого керівництва місце у
місцевих громад щодо важливості
освітнього процесу можливості його в
очному форматі щодо піклування про
знання дітей і про- про формування
власного майбутнього на сьогодні
виключно Довіра батьків Формує Формує
статус навчання дитини в тому чи іншому
регіоні Якщо батьки вважають що дитина
дитина має навчатися онлайн Ніхто
примусити її ходити офлайн не може це
наголошує буду наголошувати в нас на
нараді з прем'єр-міністром відбувалося
певні настанови щодо формування
безпечного освітнього середовища і ми
наголошуємо на тому для цього є
специфічна субвенція на 23-й рік на
формування безпечного освітнього
середовища в тих закладах принаймні
опорні та на сьогодні ще немає вкриттів
плюс Євросоюз нам виділяв 100 мільйонів
гривень на формування теж укриттів тих
школах опорних в яких немає на сьогодні
безпечних умов і ми працюємо над тим щоб
зробити слоган місце
освітній заклад є територією безпеки
реальністю Дуже дякую вам за запитання
дякуємо вам за коментарі і відповіді п
Сергію Сергію шкарлет Міністр освіти і
науки України був в Марафоні єдині
новини наживо